et autres incidents survenus à toulouse
cette fois ci dans le quartier du mirail
dans la nuit de dimanche à lundi des
policiers auraient été pris à partie
alors qu'ils étaient envoyés en renfort
auprès de pompiers pour sur un incident
un incendie de voiture elle des
agressions envers la police devenu
monnaie courante dans le quartier selon
le secrétaire du bureau départemental
d'unité sgp police des personnes en ont
volontairement incendié des containers
qu'ils avaient au préalable placé au
milieu de la voie publique ont ils
entendu volontairement un guet-apens aux
policiers qui lors de l'intervention
essuyé des tirs de projectiles des tirs
de cocktails molotov et bien sûr les
collègues rendu pour se dégager
utiliser des moyens strictement
nécessaires pour éviter que des blessés
ce sont des problèmes récurrents que
nous dénonçons régulièrement
malheureusement confinement ou pas ce
genre de délit
se répercute tout sauf un tout honneur
n'est quà et autre son de cloche du côté
de cet habitant pour qui il n'y a pas eu
de cocktails molotovs et des jets de
cailloux
en réponse à une prétendue bavure
policière ça commençait la matinée il ya
une voiture de police qui arrive et qui
ont dix ans ils ont fait des contrôles
de l'attestation et tout ça et puis
l'avait incité à dos les ans et parle
pas bien français et c'est un petit
tunisien il affine demande d'asile et
ils ont fracassé et des policiers qui
ont tapé et voilà il ya des jeunes qui
sont énervés puis voilà ils ont jeté des
trois cailloux le soir j'aime bien
gravement brûlé une voiture et voilà et
voilà ça c'est la fin de l'histoire et
policiers
ils ont encerclé le bâtiment est tous
des bâtiments plus tôt
et puis voilà ont brûlé une voiture avec
les sens et c'est tout il n'y a pas eu
de cocktail molotov avait déjà quelques
jets de pierre mais en deux minutes ils
ont encerclé tout le quartier monde est
rentré chez soi